so we already know that if we start off
with the glucose molecule
we start off with a glucose molecule
which is a six carbon molecule
six carbon molecule that this
essentially gets split in half by
glycolysis and we end up with two
pyruvic acids or two pyruvate molecules
so glycolysis literally splits this in
half it lyses the glucose and we end up
with two pyruvates or pyruvic acids
pyruvate
and these are three carbon molecules
three carbon molecules there's obviously
a lot of other stuff going on in the
carbons you saw in the past and you
could look up their chemical structures
on on the internet or wikipedia and see
them in detail but this is kind of the
important thing is that it was it was
lysed it was cut in half and this is
what happened in glycolysis
glycolysis
glycolysis and this happened in the
absence of oxygen or not necessarily it
can happen in within the presence or in
the absence of oxygen it doesn't need
oxygen and we got a net payoff of two
atps
two
atp's net
and i always say the net there because
you remember it used two atps in kind of
that investment stage and then it
generated four so it on a net basis it
generated four used to it gave us two
atps and it also produced two nadhs
two na
dhs that's what we got out of glycolysis
and just so you can visualize this a
little bit better let me draw a cell
right here
maybe i'll draw it down here
let's say i have a cell
that's its outer membrane maybe it's
nucleus we're dealing with the
eukaryotic cell
doesn't have to be the case it has this
dna in its chromatin form all spread
around like that and then you have some
mitochondria and you know there's a
reason why people call it the power
centers of the cell we'll we'll look at
that in a second so there's a
mitochondria it has an outer membrane an
inner membrane just like that
i'll do more detail on the structure of
a mitochondria maybe later in this video
or maybe i'll do a whole video on them
that's another mitochondria
right there
and then all of this fluidic space out
here that's between the organelles or in
the organelles you can view them as
parts of the cell that are you know they
do specific things they do specific
things kind of like organs do specific
things within our own bodies
so this so between all of the organelles
you have just this fluidic space this is
just fluid of the cell and that's called
the cytoplasm
cytoplasm and that's where glycolysis
occurs
so glycolysis occurs in the cytoplasm
glycolysis
now we all know in the overview video we
we know what the next step is it's this
the krebs cycle or the citric acid cycle
and that actually takes place in the
inner membrane
or the inner i shouldn't say the inner
space
the inner space of these mitochondria
let me draw it a little bit bigger let
me draw a mitochondria here
so if this is a mitochondria it has an
outer membrane it has an inner membrane
if i have just one inner membrane we
call it a crista if we have many we call
them cristae
these little convoluted inner membrane
let me give it a label
i'll say there are cristae
plural
and then it has two compartments right
it's because it's divided by these two
membranes this compartment right here is
called the outer compartment this whole
thing right there that's the outer
compartment and then this inner
compartment in here
this inner compartment in here is called
the matrix
the inner compartment right there is
called the matrix now you have these
pyruvates they're not quite just ready
for the krebs cycle but
i guess well that's a good it's a good
intro to what how do you make them ready
for the krebs cycle they actually get
oxidized and i'll just focus on one of
these pyruvates
and we just have to remember that the
pyruvate that this happens twice for
every molecule of glucose so we have
this kind of preparation step step for
for the krebs cycle we call that
pyruvate
oxidation pyruvate
oxidation and essentially what it does
is it cleaves one of these carbons off
of the pyruvate and so you end up with a
two carbon compound
you don't have just two carbons but its
backbone of carbons is just two carbons
called acetyl coa
acetyl
coa and if these names are confusing
because you know what's acetyl coenzyme
a these are very bizarre you could do a
web search on it but i'm just going to
use the words right now because it'll
keep things simple and we'll get the big
picture so it generates acetyl coa which
is this two carbon compound it also
it also
reduces some nad plus
to na
d8
and this process right here is often a
given credit or or the krebs cycle the
citric acid cycle gets credit for this
step but it's really a preparation step
for the krebs cycle now once you have
this two carbon
once you have this two carbon chain
acetyl-coa right here you are ready to
jump into
the krebs cycle this long talked about
krebs cycle and you'll see in a second
why it's called a cycle the acetyl-coa
and all of this is catalyzed by enzymes
and enzymes are just proteins that bring
together the constituent things that
need to react in the right way so that
they do react so catalyzed by enzymes
this acetyl coa merges with some
oxaloa
acid very fancy word but this is a four
carbon
molecule
this is a four carbon molecule right
here these two guys are kind of reacted
together or merged together depending on
how you want to view it
draw it like that it's all catalyzed by
enzymes it's important you know some
tests will say is this an enzyme
catalyzed reaction yes everything in the
krebs cycle is an enzyme catalyzed
reaction and they form
citrate or citric acid
citric
acid which is the same stuff in your
lemonade or your orange juice and this
is a
six carbon
six carbon molecule
which makes sense you have a two carbon
and a four carbon you get a six carbon
molecule and then the citric acid is
then oxidized over a bunch of steps and
this is a huge simplification here but
it's just oxidized over a bunch of steps
again the carbons are cleaved off both
two carbons are cleaved off of it to get
back to
oxaloacetic acid and you might be saying
hey when these carbons are cleaved off
like you know when let's say this carbon
is cleaved off what happens to it
it gets
it becomes co2 it gets put onto some
oxygen and leaves the system so this is
where the oxygen or the carbons
or the carbon dioxide actually gets
formed and similarly when these carbons
get cleaved off it forms co2
and actually for every molecule of
glucose you have six carbons
when you do this whole process once
you're generating three molecules of
carbon dioxide but you're gonna do it
twice you're gonna have six carbons uh
six carbon dioxides produced which
accounts for
all of the carbons right you get rid of
three carbons for every turn of this
well two for every turn but really for
the steps after glycolysis you get rid
of three carbons but you're going to do
it for each of the pyruvates you're
going to get rid of all six carbons
which will have to exhale eventually but
this cycle it doesn't just generate
carbons the whole idea is to generate
nadhs and fadh2s and atps
so you know right here and this is a
huge simplification i'll show you the
detailed picture in a second
we'll reduce some nad
into nadh
nad plus into nadh we'll do it again and
of course these are in separate steps
there's intermediate compounds i'll show
you those in a second nad plus will
another nad plus molecule will be
reduced to na
nadh maybe we'll produce some
some atp will turn to
or some adp will turn to atp
adp turning into atp maybe we have some
not maybe this is what happens some fad
gets let me write it this way
some fad
gets oxidized into fadh2 and the whole
reason why we even pay attention to
these you know you you might think hey
cellular respiration is all about atp
why do we even pay attention to these
nadhs and these fad h2s that get
produced as part of the process the
reason why we care is that these are the
inputs into the electron transport chain
these get oxidized or they lose their
hydrogens the electron transport chain
and that's where the bulk of the atp is
actually produced and then maybe we'll
have another
nad get reduced or gain in hydrogen
right reduction is gaining an electron
or gaining a hydrogen whose electron you
can hog
in a d h and then we end up backs at a
oxaloacetic acid and we can perform the
whole citric acid cycle over again
so now that we've written it all out
let's account for what we have
so
depending on let me draw some dividing
lines so we know what's what so this
right here
this right here everything to the left
of that line right there is glycolysis
glycolysis we learned that already and
then most especially introductory
textbooks will give
the krebs cycle credit for this pyruvate
oxidation but that's really a
preparatory stage the krebs cycle is
really formally this part where you
start with acetyl coa you merge it with
oxaloacetic acid and then you go and you
form citric acid and you you which
essentially gets oxidized and produces
all of these things that will need to
either directly produce atp or you do it
indirectly in in the electron transport
chain but let's account for everything
that we have
let's account for everything that we
have so far we already accounted for the
glycolysis right there two net atps two
nadhs
now in the citric acid cycle or in the
krebs cycle well first we have our
pyruvate oxidation that produced one
nadh
one nadh
but remember if we want to say what are
we producing for every glucose
this is what we produced for each of the
pyruvates right this was from 180 dh
from just this pyruvate but by clock but
glycolysis produced two pyruvates so
everything after this we're gonna
multiply we're gonna multiply by two for
every molecule of glucose
so i'll say for so the pyruvate
oxidation times two means that we got
two nadhs
two
na
dhs right there
and then when we look at
this side when the formal krebs cycle
what do we get we have how many nadhs
one
two
three nadhs so three
nadhs
times two because we're going to perform
this cycle for each of the pyruvates
produced from glycolysis
so that gives us six nadhs
we have one atp per turn of the cycle
that's going to happen twice once for
each pyruvic acid so we get two
atps and then we have one
f a d h two but it's good we're gonna do
this cycle twice this is per cycle so
times two
we have two f a
d h's
now sometimes in a lot of books these
two nadhs or per turn of the krebs cycle
or per pyruvate this one nadh they'll
give credit to the krebs cycle for that
so sometimes instead of having this
intermediate step they'll just write
four nadhs right here and you're gonna
do it twice once for each pyruvate so
they'll say eight nadhs get produced
from the krebs cycle but the reality is
six from the krebs cycle two from the
preparatory stage
now the interesting thing is we can now
account whether we get to the 38 atps
promised by cellular respiration we've
directly already produced for every
molecule of glucose two atps and then
two more atps so we have four atps
four atps how many nadhs do we have two
four and then four plus six is ten we
have ten
ten nadhs
and then we have two fadhs two f a
d h
twos i think in the first video on
cellular respiration i said fadh it
should be fadh2 just to be particular
about things and these so you might say
hey you know where's our 38 atps we only
have four atps right now but these are
actually the inputs in the electron
transport chain these molecules right
here get oxidized in the electron
transport chain every nadh in the
electron transport chain produces three
atps so these 10 nadhs are going to
produce 30 atps
in the electron
transport chain and each fadh2 when it
gets oxidized and gets turned back into
fad in the electron transport chain
will produce two atp so two of them are
going to produce four
atps
in the
electron transport chain so we now see
we get four from just what we've done so
far glycolysis the preparatory stage and
the krebs or citric acid cycle and then
eventually these outputs from glycolysis
and the citric acid cycle when they get
into the electron transport chain are
going to produce another 34. so 34 plus
4 it does get us to the promised 38 atp
that you would expect that you would
expect in a a super efficient cell this
is kind of the theoretical maximum in
most cells they really don't get quite
there but this is a good number to know
if you're going to take the ap bio test
or in most introductory biology courses
there's one other point i want to make
here everything we've talked about so
far this is carbohydrate metabolism or
sugar catabolism we could call it we're
breaking down sugars to produce atp
glucose was our starting point but
animals including us we can we can
catabolize other things we can
catabolize proteins
we can catabolize proteins we can
catabolize
we can catabolize fats and if you have
any fat on your body you have energy you
you're in theory your body should be
able to take that fat and you should be
able to do things with that you should
be able to generate atp
and the interesting thing the reason why
i bring it out up here is obviously
glycolysis is of no use to these things
although fats can be turned into into
glucose in the liver but what the
interesting thing is that the the krebs
cycle is the entry point for these other
catabolic mechanisms proteins can be
broken down into amino acids which can
be broken down into acetyl coa fats can
be turned into into glucose which
actually could then go the whole
cellular respiration but the
the big picture here is acetyl coa
is the general catabolic kind of
intermediary that can then enter the
krebs cycle and generate atp regardless
of whether our fuel is carbohydrates
sugars proteins
or fats now we have a good sense of how
everything works out right now i think
now i'm going to show you kind of a
diagram that you might see in your in
your biology textbook or the i'll
actually show the actual diagram from
wikipedia and i just want to show you
this looks very daunting and very
confusing and i think that's why many of
us have trouble with with cellular
respiration initially because there's
just so much information it's hard to
process what's important but i want to
just highlight the important steps here
just so you see it's the same thing that
we talked about
from glycolysis you produce two
pyruvates that's the pyruvate right
there they actually show its molecular
structure this is the pyruvate oxidation
step that i talked about the preparatory
step
and you see we produce a carbon dioxide
and we reduce an nad plus into
nadh then we're ready to enter the krebs
cycle the acetyl and the oxaloacetate
or oxaloacetic acid they are reacted
together to perform to create citric
acid they've actually drawn the molecule
there and then the citric acid is
oxidized through the krebs cycle right
there this all of these steps each of
these steps are facilitated by enzymes
and it gets oxidized but i want to
highlight the interesting parts
here we have an nad
get reduced to nadh we have another nad
get reduced to nadh and then over here
another nad get reduced to nadh so so
far if you include the preparatory step
we have
four nadhs formed three directly from
the krebs cycle that's just what i told
you
now we have in this diagram they say gdp
or gtp gets formed from gdp the gtp is
just guanosine triphosphate it's another
purine that can that can be a source of
energy but then that later can be used
to form an atp so this is just the way
they happen to draw it but this is the
actual atp that i drew in the diagram on
top and then they have this q group and
i won't go into it and then it gets
reduced over here it gets those two
hydrogens but that essentially ends up
reducing the fadh2s so this is where the
fad
fadh2 gets
produced so as promised we produced for
each pyruvate that inputted remember so
we're going to do it twice for each
pyruvate we produced one two three four
nadhs
we produced one atp and one
fadh2 and that's exactly what we saw
what we saw up here i'll see in the next
video